[creator] Okay, so
[creator] Back again
[creator] The developer start menu is done. I just told it that I wanted to add a back to main menus
[creator] Button in the pause menu because there's no way to go back to the main menu unless you refresh
[creator] Anyway, here's the dev start menu
[creator] You can choose
[creator] see this is just shows you how big things are some like we were just once
[creator] very very tiny I'm actually gonna show you the black hole and I worry about
[creator] selecting everything this what happens when you get to the black hole stage it
[creator] gets kind of crazy you're also other black holes that are way bigger let's
[creator] try this out I'm just gonna start oh beat it never
[creator] thought I'd have to get bigger like the other ones oh well so far I'd say the
[creator] clone is a big success like this is definitely a game I could see myself
[creator] just playing when I'm bored or I'm just like kind of just chilling anyway I'm
[creator] gonna get a website spun up that I can just host all of my like browser based
[agent_tts] Rigel is done
[creator] I've no idea how long this video is gonna be I might start another project
[creator] and have Orbit actually just edit this video for me and just choose all the
[creator] highlights and just make it for me okay goodbye